I think you've a bit of cool ready which
is that this is a quotient right it's
sign my closet you can treat the top is
view bottom of e and then you can use
I've even written it over there on the
right hand board right you can use the
cushion just like we used it before
right that cause and then the question
rule tells me is you - you - in this
case is the derivative of sine X but I
know what that is it's cause so I'm
gonna write clothes there it is there's
V you - you okay with that
here comes you V - what's you sine X
very good and then I have to do V - now
here's B so so V - will be minus sine X
watch out for that all divided by B
squared which is in this case is cos X
all squared okay now what we can do is
we can do some canceling but you have to
be careful with how you do it okay now
quick note for you and I'm gonna flag
this because it happens in the textbook
see how we're adding this is cos X all
squared can I ask you all to look at
this because it's common mistake and
it's kind of just a very minor issue of
notation right have a look at my
denominator please note that I have
written it with brackets I have not
written this if you see this it's much
more likely to actually mean this which
we have to deal with just yet but you
will eventually okay
so that's why instead of having the
squared here the whole thing is being
squared the cosine is also being squared
so the convention even though honestly
it's slightly weird is to put that to
that power is to put it after the COS
like so okay this is ring some bells
you might remember just doing this Miami
zoo this double negative positive how am
I gonna write this sign with the squared
after the sign
and then the X and then on the
denominator cause squared X just like we
saw before okay now it's tempting to
want to cancel the cos squared with this
cos squared right it is very tempting
but something even better than this is
to say that numerator it's been a while
it's been a while but you have an
identity for this
don't shout out but who remembers what
the identity who has it somewhere
kicking around the memory okay all right
for those of you who don't grab your
calculator out okay we can't prove this
we did prove it but I want to remind you
what it is don't tell the person next to
you because I want you to have a
different angle to the person next to
you a pick and angle any egg you like
and then into your calculator input COS
of that angle I'm gonna spoil it and say
I'm gonna put 31 degrees and like that
COS of that angle squared plus sine of
that angle and then square okay now I
really hope you randomly choose an angle
different to the person next to you and
then once you've hit equals you can all
hold up your car cane and look at each
other because you will have the same
answer right what do you got did you get
one if you didn't get one you punch this
in your calculator okay cuz squared X
for sine squared X no matter what angle
you put it's always equals exactly one
so I can write it like so okay now
that's pretty good I'm happy with that
but you can go one final step better cuz
I'm lazy I don't like writing fractions
think we have some identities for when
we don't like writing reciprocals of
fractions but what's it called when I
turn this thing upside down what's it
called she starts with an S and then you
go hello brother Joe SEC right this is
SEC the reciprocal is of cos is sick but
there's a squared that's it right there